- I actually did feel very guilty
I had a lot of inner
conflict for many years
when I first began the sport.
I felt that maybe I was
going against my religion
and it really really
used to tear me apart.
At the same time I loved the sport
and I couldn't understand
how that could be wrong.
I realized that I was
living a double life.
One that I was a nice,
traditional girl at home,
and the other where I succumb to the gym
and that was another side of me.
I remember the first time
I walked into the gym
I was 18 years of age
It was quite a male-dominated environment
but none of that fazed me.
All I wanted to do was
participate in the sport.
Muay Thai originally was designed
as a warfare art by the Thais.
They used to use it to
defend their country.
It is known as the art of eight limbs,
it's full-speed, full-pace, full-power,
and it's one of the
hardest sports in the world
so it can be quite intimidating.
(martial yells)
- To the right, Begum. To the right.
- [Ruqsana] I actually began
my sport training with Bill.
He's actually become like
a father figure to me.
He's took me under his wing.
At the same time he puts on his coach hat,
he means business.
I can't come up with
excuses, I can't moan about
that I'm in pain or I'm having a bad day.
When you're in training
mode, you're in training.
The fact that I come from a
traditional Muslim background
is quite unusual to pursue
a sport such as Muay Thai.
I was afraid that my family
might tell me sport, or them.
I remember coming home one
day, and my father looked at me
and he said to me "Why do
you walk like a boxer?"
At that point I was so
frightened that the sport
would be taken away from
me I ran up to my room,
I had one trophy.
I hid that, because I
thought that's the one key
that gave it away that
I might be doing boxing.
I decided to tell them,
and I brought my father down
to the gym to reassure him
that all I was doing was
exercising some discipline
in my life rather than
being out on the street
getting involved with
things that I shouldn't be.
Just knowing that they know
what I'm doing in my spare time,
that's enough for me to
continue and make them proud.
I don't want to walk away,
sitting in the changing room
crying my eyes out, thinking
I could have done better
or actually I had it in me to
win that fight but I gave up.
(crowd cheers)
- [Announcer] In the left corner, Ruqsana!
- [Ruqsana] It's just me against her.
Forget about her coaches,
forget about her supporters,
it's all about what I can do
in these ten minutes of my life.
- Round one
(bell rings)
(crowd cheers)
- [Ruqsana] You don't
really have time for nerves
all you're thinking about
is your next strike,
your strategy: is it working, is it not,
am I hurting my opponent,
am I winning the fight
or do I need to change,
so it's very tactical.
(crowd cheers)
Obviously if you get
caught with a nasty shot
you're trying to phase
that out very quickly
and get back onto your game plan.
(yells)
(bell rings)
(crowd cheers)
- [Announcer] The winner
is, in the red corner,
(crowd cheers)
Ruqsana!
A round of applause, please
give it up for Susanna.
(crowd cheers)
- [Ruqsana] To win a
fight is one of the most
amazing feeling in the world.
it just reassures you
that all that hard work,
all that sacrifice, everything
that everyone around you,
the team around you, the nutritionists,
your training partners,
all those nights training,
sparring, going home with
bruises, all that is worthwhile.
Talent alone is not enough,
it's all about sacrifice,
it's all about being dedicated.
And it's never the end, until you give up.